a member of that super bowl winning team
two-time super bowl champ
and he's got a terrific podcast called
green light
chris long back on the rich eisen show
how are you chris
i'm good podcast not bad today kind of
sucks well i saw that
um chris on on twitter uh i have this in
my back pocket i might as well put it on
the table right here i did notice
um you know that you tweeted out before
our show green light will be out later
today and then the string went
to maybe and then it's out it sucks
enjoy i think you've got to work on your
promotion game
chris not to tell you like the promotion
thing because then you might over
promise
under deliver so does it really suck
were you not pleased with the result of
who's on what are you what are you
talking about it was just me and my
co-host we didn't have a guest everybody
big-timed us and then you know we kind
of ended up with nothing to talk about
after this weekend in sports like i
don't know we just had the the the
schedule
we had the draft right didn't feel like
there was anything going on the playing
game is like uh
the playing games are happening over the
next two days right yeah so we didn't
really have anything you ever have days
like that rich
well today's that day chris thanks for
coming on that's why you called
no me be honest you called me because
there was a white pass rusher this time
with philly
you triangulated that in your head and i
loved how you texted me like how you
been buddy
why'd you come on the show no hold on a
second about some random stuff
chris now then i did say this at the top
of the show i always shoot everybody
straight chris did i not bring this up
my chris chris brockman they're gonna
bring this up okay
you did i brought it up that i did see
you trending on twitter yesterday
i found out why you were trending i am
not having you on to talk about ryan
kerrigan we will talk about it i mean
because that is a
story but but i did did say you know
what hey
i like talking to chris it's been a
while i'd love to chat with him i'd love
to hear what he has to say i always find
it interesting to talk to people and i
told you i like talking to interesting
people
that's the way you know otherwise i'm
wasting my time on this show listen when
i woke up yesterday and i was trending
i thought maybe i died and i was like my
ghost holding my phone and people were
saying either nice
things about me or i got canceled i
didn't know what happened like when
you're trending it's not good
if you don't know why you're trending so
then how does it land on chris long that
chris long is trending because ryan
carrigan
uh left washington football team to go
to philadelphia
how does that happen because the
entirety of my mentions are like same
guy
and i was like well that's a great
compliment to me i mean ryan kerrigan's
a hell of a player
i think he's going to help him um but i
also know philly fans
every time we we sign any white edge
rusher whether he's an unsigned
undrafted free agent he's going to get
the chris long comp now
that's when you texted me i read that
out before he said what's up man
white edge rusher bat signal question
mark
that's that what you needed
[Music]
send up the white edge rusher bat signal
get me chris long
yeah it shouldn't be it shouldn't be me
for the record but i just have a podcast
hey look but you you won a super bowl
yeah i mean when you your kevin hart
stuff was pretty right on
he was he said that you guys were
confident going into that super bowl
that the defense could get after brady
you did a fellow michigan man actually
did
nail brady and did knock a ball loose
and in a very big moment
uh obviously you were involved points
huh
82 points he wasn't far off he did say
that kevin
that well the 83 was going to be all
philadelphia's points but
it was wrong about one thing they scored
a lot too i know they did score a lot
as well so what what what do you make of
the nfc east right now
uh as we are in the middle of may this
is something we can start to look over
the steering wheel
because the one thing that i did see uh
very very few times does the
schedule release actually inform me of
something but when i saw washington
football
team schedule and the final five games
are all in the nfc east that means that
that the reigning division winner won't
play
many division games until december which
means this division's flat out up for
grabs
it's the way i look yeah which is which
is uh
how it always seems to be one way or
another uh lately i don't know um
i i'm excited about the division because
you know all the teams can go any which
way right
like we don't know what to expect with
anybody and i'm more like the person who
likes chaos with the schedule
um i i like you know like sign me up for
the darnold revenge game i know you're
going to be watching but like
that's going to get more eyes you know
in my household than some marquee match
up because i like the chaos so
i think you know having all those
division games at the end and with the
new
week in the schedule one of the biggest
concerns is like maybe these week 18
games or you know aren't going to matter
as much
but they really backloaded the
conference games and a team like
washington
well i'm excited about actually um you
know fits magic's there and
i love the young core they built and
defensive lineman
has been on some really good hustle
defensive lines that played
you know balls to the wall that's the
kind of group they have so it's easy to
watch them
um i think they have as good a chance as
anybody of being in it at the end and
the reality is they're all going to have
a great chance you know one thing
coaches want to tell their players
is hey it's all right in front of us you
ask any player
that's the thing that coach tells you
after you lose a tough game or he cusses
you out but at the end he says
it's all right in front of us and team
like washington team like philly you
know
the entire nfc east is going to have
that opportunity and there's teams like
denver
if you look at denver's schedule uh you
know i gave them out as one
one team that i like their upside
whether they get aaron or not
because all their conference games are
going to be after their bye week and
late in the season
and they've got a chance to get out
ahead of it early and so you can keep
teams engaged that way because you know
you're still in it so when you look at
the eagles though
like we had howie roseman on the week
after the draft
and you know jalen hurts is there and i
asked him is this a one-year tryout for
jalen hurts because the
acquisition of wence will most likely
net the team
based on the trade that they also made
with miami atop the draft this year
three first rounders next year meaning
they could draft whoever their darn well
please essentially next year by
aggregating these picks together or
maybe
trading those picks away for somebody
that might
pop free if you know potentially in a
trade
what do you think their long-term plan
is in philadelphia well i i gotta think
i gotta think they're evaluating right i
mean like you come in this year you know
like you like some things you see with
jalen i certainly like
everything i see from the neck up like
to me i wanna i wanna see more than four
games of him playing quarterback right i
think it's natural because
we we saw seasons of carson wentz and
the same people calling for jalen hurts
are telling me
uh you know we've seen enough jaylen
hurts after four games and
carson was an mvp for a year and look
where he ended up so you know it's
it's a small sample size i think you
know development of this young
quarterback is going to be big
but i think he's like you know
consummate kind of leader
locker room guy so you have that to
start with but the truth is and
as it often is with college football
it's like you don't really know who the
quarterbacks are next year i mean like
and next year the way you look at it
there's only a few names i even know now
i'm no expert when you talk to people
that are experts
it's not like a hallmark quarterback
year but you're right
they grab some capital because they want
to possibly well this isn't just why
they did it but it helps
next year they can reach up and snag
that quarterback in the future if they
don't think jalen's the guy um
and you know i think one of the keys you
have to look at is
who are the teams that are going to just
flat out suck this year
you know do those teams have their guy
and because of the influx of young
quarterbacks i do think there will be
some teams
a lot of jacksonville no offense to jets
who i'm really excited about
um but you can't put all your eggs in
that basket they could be a bottom five
team just by virtue of needing to work
on that roster and big joe douglas will
but you know it takes time their teams
that are gonna have their quarterback
and maybe a top pick
so you're kind of rooting for the teams
that are set with their guys
to struggle next year and then you have
the capital and you have the
flexibility to move up if jaylen's not
the guy chris long here on the rich
eisen
rich eisen show two-time super bowl
champion and uh
the host of green light co-host of green
light podcast
um which you should go get despite him
saying this latest thing
sucks any other day that but today but
um what
what do you think is going on with aaron
rodgers ear to the ground talking to
people
not even not even that but what what
what do you think is up
with him in green bay man i just think
it's one of those things that
you have to consider aaron's entire
experience in football like his
formative years have been
like anybody would say they'd want to be
aaron rodgers right like we'd all trade
places right but
at the same time like you know to aaron
rodgers you know it's all he knows is
being aaron rodgers and it wasn't always
easy
uh you know i know nobody's gonna feel
sorry for him now but you know juco kid
right
cal guy wasn't like a you know a
heralded star in college and was
a guy who sat and gave the nfl free
b-roll i always tell guys i'm like do
you really want to sit
in that draft room and give the nfl free
b-roll for a decade um
he gave him plenty and then sat behind
farm and those
differences were documented and then the
entire you know draft pick
deficit there when it comes to
investment and like outwardly at the top
of the draft what he wants to do
and i think the worst part about aaron
is even when he succeeds he's he's
he's arguing against himself because
i don't know how those guys would be a
lot of the guys he's thrown to south of
devante jones i don't know
but devonte adam sorry um i don't know
who those guys are and that's what aaron
does he makes everybody better
so like even when when you know if
you're trying to make a case that he
doesn't have enough weapons he's so good
he's going to elevate god's games
to the point where they are scoring 30
again so i think you know there's a chip
on his shoulder
and i think what he wants is security
and the only way you prove to a
quarterback like that
that he has security in the building
where he's won a super bowl and wants to
win two
you know brett won one and you know um
there's a certain quarterback
played 16 years there he's on his 16th
or 17th year like yep
i think he wants to finish in green bay
and i think it's just up to green bay
to say like hey we we're not going to
stick to our plan we had two years ago
when we bet on his demise he just
played like an mvp so let's be logical
about this
we got the ball is coming off his arm
like nothing you'd ever seen
and he's 38 years old so like it's time
to not bet against him
and show him some love and i think like
if he got traded
like let's say you got traded denver
rich what are they not going to have
by virtue of him getting traded to
denver the two first-round picks that
he's arguing like hell over
filling with a weapon so you know
it's kind of a wash for him i think the
best chance he has to win it all is in
green bay
i think they have to commit to him i
agree with you and then but here's my
question for you chris long
because you know security is definitely
one thing
and you know i totally understand that
and then you pointed out rightfully so
that he makes guys better
and that um he knows who he's throwing
to and he knows which guys he can make
better just by
that aspect and then you hear that the
cutting of jake kumaro after he said
last september that
he loves this kid he thinks that he can
throw him they cut him the next day
as he said the last time i said publicly
i like somebody who wound up in buffalo
referring to this kid so so my question
for you is
would you do you like the idea of
allowing a quarterback to
have a say in roster building would you
say that that is a good way to go about
things
in the nfl i think he deserves a seat at
the table i think quarterbacks transcend
and listen i hit him for a living and
most defensive players will tell you we
don't like him or whatever but like
you can't win without one you can but
it's going to be an interesting process
in building
and is it sustainable to win without one
year after year
like you could you know have your one
year where the defense is the top five
defense and that sort of thing but
i just i feel like you got to have a
seat at the table and i think we worry
about the slippery slope thing where
like i was gonna turn to the nba it's
gonna turn into like a
like a league where players you just
have all to say like you know whether
you like that or not
it's not because there's not many aaron
rodgers so why are we worried about it
being a slippery slope and it's not like
the packers um are necessarily
like the the world's best you know have
the world's best draft history i mean
i'm not saying they're the worst i'm not
saying they're the best but i think he
at least deserves a place in the table
when talking about
offensive personnel and the same thing
with russell and the same thing with
like any top five quarterback in the
league it's not that hard to tell who
should who shouldn't be talking about
this stuff
there's a mendoza line for quarterbacks
we talked about on the pod like where's
that mendoza line for quarterbacks the
south of here should just shut up
but it's up to that quarterback to know
yeah
i i you know you heard ron wolf
basically say that uh
quarterbacks or divas terry bradshaw you
know
say that uh aaron in particular is weak
because of all this and
i don't understand that you know concept
because they know
more than anybody else certainly ron
wolf that the financial construct of the
league under the new cba
does not mean that like say for bradshaw
mark malone gets drafted that they have
to play back in 1980 they didn't have to
play him by year three to see if there
was a fifth year option to pick up and
ron wolfe didn't have to build a team
under that construct either like the
minute
you draft somebody like jordan love you
know the kids got to get on the field
within three years and so does aaron he
doesn't want to give him another freebie
in 2021 like he did
last year like i thought i thought and i
love terry terry's like a family member
to me and it's okay i disagree with my
dad on stuff all the time so
he's my dad's brother you know i'ma
disagree with him sometimes but like
i i i didn't agree and i thought it was
apples to oranges and
um i think you talk about leverage
um you know and yeah we don't read
people up this early
generally in the nfl well they read the
hop up like sight unseen
last year in arizona you know and
certainly he deserved that
but there is a precedent that if there's
a guy that
you really want to take care of you can
do it especially when he's the reason
that you've been relevant as a franchise
like you know how lucky you are as a
franchise to go from like brett farve to
another hall of famer
like it's incredible in indy for a
second we thought we were going that way
with peyton to andrew and andrew left
early
and you know it just goes to show how
lucky you are as a franchise when you go
from one hall of famer to the next
you owe him you owe him a little
something and especially when the the
the franchise is leverage is sitting
right there in the meeting room
he's sitting right there in the meeting
room every day staring you in the face
like of course you're gonna come to the
table with a chip on your shoulder you
bet against me
and that's the thing about like you know
disconnect this teams can bet against
players players can't bet against teams
it's like the allegiance has to be 100
one way
but not the other way and that's kind of
a tired complaint but
you know we're talking about the best in
the game you know i i i do think at some
point you gotta
you gotta commit to him before we let
chris long go into his tuesday
uh um chris brockman ask him the poll
question
which you can take for tomorrow's green
light if you want go for it
two a week all right so that your next
green light your next yeah yeah chris
this is a good one
who most needs to be freed from their
current team
aaron rodgers zion williamson shohei
ohtani
man i would say it's zion because
you know it's must-see tv right i mean
everybody's
clamoring around the tv to see him play
and he's going to be probably on the
edge of making the playoffs right
uh in perpetuity in new orleans in my
opinion so
i would like to see zion free because
aaron's doing he's knocking on the door
you know this is just an interpersonal
problem that they have to work out
and then the otani kid everything seems
pretty good for him too doesn't it
well yes except uh you know you see the
track record of mike trout the modern
day mantle
and i'm concerned about the modern day
ruth doing what he's doing and obviously
can become generationally wealthy but
i mean trout's unbelievable huh i've
never seen anything like it
honestly i feel like we've we're already
desensitized so i
yeah i've scrolled to a highlight
earlier of this guy hitting like a
four 450 foot dinger and was just like
oh he had another home run it's a
pitcher dude he's
enormous he is enormous i i you know
i've i've
i've never seen him in person i would
love to stand next to him
he looks enormous he looks like he looks
like a tight end
he really does he's unbelievable this
guy we don't make a big enough deal
about this
alien yeah hey alien we which we talked
about yesterday
like because you know there are ufos as
you saw in 60 minutes this past week
well now they're calling them
you apps that's right uap uaps
yeah you wanna leave rich oh my god the
truth is out there chris long are you
kidding me yes it is
damn straight it is all right thanks
thanks for the call oh one last thing
before i let you go we also noticed this
on your your twitter feed um
as well uh mark ingram complaining that
his bags get lost
uh by united airlines you change
your your name and avatar with the blue
check mark so if you don't see the at
joel 91 it looks like
united airlines is responding you're
rich buy
clothes fantastic
did i lie when you land and you have
clothes like and you're rich you go buy
some clothes but i was just busting
mark's ball
i know i love mark when i play mark he's
always smiling it's hard to be tough
around mark
but like he's the best dude in the world
so i picked him a soft target
but he was going to be all angry at me
and he got it pretty
pretty quickly but a lot of people were
thinking man the united guy was like
he had one of those uh fufu you're cool
i'm out like uh like moments where so
i've done this to pledge to cox before i
did it with delta a couple years ago it
happened
you know what the best part about rich
yes this dude
has regular guy luggage when he tweeted
the picture of like hey united i found
my luggage no mark i found your luggage
you're welcome
um he had a big nike bag that looked
like he was 10 years old
i thought he was going to have skill guy
luggage so i came away with thinking
even higher
of mark ingram than i did when i pulled
the prank but the fact is that
so many people had to think united
airlines was just had enough they were
out of you know what's to give
and it just said you know you're rich
buy clothes oh my gosh that's that's
well done chris well the social media
guy is probably the least important guy
at uh at an airline that flies big
airplanes so if if that was the case it
wouldn't be that bad well the same
person that uh that tweeted out that
andy dalton was qb1 and then justin
fields was acquired so it's probably the
same person
bad day at the office i know chris
thanks
thanks
for the time always appreciate it and uh
i i
i can't wait for the next uh reason for
you to trend so i reach out to you
okay well maybe jared allen will sign
someone
outstanding pull thanks for the call
chris appreciate it it's chris long
everybody
i love talking to him smart
funny good lord hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here